we're joined by Gordon Chang he's a
columnist for The Daily Beast and the
author of the book nuclear showdown
North Korea takes on the world
Gordon good morning good morning so it
is about 7:30 4:00 p.m. in Pyongyang
there has not been a nuclear test as yet
what is your expectation for this
weekend well it won't be this weekend
but North Korea has already completed
all of the initial preparations they've
taken the device they put it into a
tunnel they've sealed it and all they're
waiting for is an order from Kim jong-un
the ruler of North Korea they've got to
do it sometime because they sell these
things to the Iranians and they also
need to prove to the world that they're
their nukes works so it will occur at
some point North Korea has said it's its
swords are drawn and it's talking openly
about pre-emptive strikes is this the
most aggressive tone we've seen from
this regime it's the most aggressive but
we have heard this in the past and so
they've been talking about pre-emptive
strikes now for a couple years now of
course they're not going to do it
they're just trying to deter the United
States they're very concerned I'm sure
about the missile strikes on Syria
because that showed that President Trump
had a low threshold for the use of force
and also the detonation of that mother
of all bombs on Thursday that probably
frightened the North Koreans because you
know that was going after an underground
network north korea has more than any
other country has buried its military
facilities and government offices
underground gordon there's a lot of talk
about us North Korea relations but I
wonder how you see this playing out in
the region we know that China the
Chinese have basically been the biggest
supporter of this North Korean regime as
of the first quarter of this year
Chinese trade has increased with North
Korea by I think thirty seven point four
percent in the first quarter is your
expectation that the Chinese can be
counted on to curb any of North Korea's
nuclear ambitions well for the next
couple months yes because President
Trump and other countries have put
pressure on Beijing but afterwards you
know the pattern has always been in the
past that when we start to pay attention
to something else then the Chinese go
back to their old way of doing things
which is supporting North Korea so for
instance on February 18th they announced
that ban on purchasing of North Korea
and call when we weren't looking a
couple weeks later there were North
Korea
and coal ships in Chinese ports
unloading and so you know it's all a
question of what we do in terms of
putting the pressure on Beijing a vice
president Mike Pence arrives in South
Korea tomorrow what are you expecting
from that visit and what are you
expecting from US policy at this point
well US policy in the Trump
administration has been to reassure
Tokyo and Seoul and so you saw Tillerson
the Secretary of State James Madison
Terry of Defense they've all gone to
this route into the region and there is
even some talk that Trump's first
foreign trip could very well be to Japan
so this is really a question of
reassuring our friends and allies
because at this point we're going to
need all the help we can get Gordon you
mentioned the detonation of the what is
being called the mother of all bombs and
of course the tomahawk airstrike in
Syria does that have the effect of
ratcheting this up in the eyes of Kim
jong-un the North Korean leader or is it
a deterrent well it's both but certainly
in Kim jong-un's eyes this is something
really serious because his father Kim
jong-il spent about six weeks in a
bunker during the 2003 Iraq war he was
so concerned about george w bush but you
know the United States needs to deter
the North Koreans and in the past we
haven't done as much as we should have
and that's why we have all of our
leaders going to Seoul and Tokyo so it's
important for us to do that but on the
other hand the line between provocation
and deterrence is really really thin
yeah Gordon quickly do you believe that
they have a missile to constructus at
this point they have three missiles the
type of dong to the K no.8 and kn-14
they can reach the lower 48 states they
haven't been tested but I'm sure that
they work the only thing they can't do
is put a nuke to them but you know
that's about four years down the road
all right Gordon Chang thank you so much
for being with us this morning
thank you